[SOUND LOGO]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Thank
you all for coming.
So we're entering the last
one-third of the class.
I guess the best way to talk
about that would be schedule.
So we're down to these--
you just had your second exam.
And the last and
final problem set
was released a bit
late over the weekend.
But anyway, you
should have it now.
So what we're going to do is
the welfare theorems today.
And then things like existence
of competitive equilibria
and Nash equilibria,
Gorman aggregation,
when we're allowed to look at
that representative household
or not.
And thinking about whether
models identify data.
In fact, whether you could
reject a model based on data.
So these first four lectures
are all in general equilibrium
but nevertheless do
link to other themes
that we've been
covering in the class.
And then, the last few lectures
go back to the welfare theorems
and talk about how
they can fail but,
in particular, also how you
can construct market remedies
for failures.
And then, we end
with monetary theory.
So about, I guess, seven
or so lectures left.
And then, if we look on the
reading list, optimality
and competitive equilibria.
This was the welfare
theorem lecture.
And there's only
one starred reading,
which is Kreps, section 6.3.
So again, I do recommend
that you look at-- this
is more textbook style.
But it is written at a
fairly straightforward level.
And I think you
will find it useful.
So let me start
in on lecture 16.
So the fundamental
welfare theorems,
there are two of them.
That's going to be
the focus today.
First one, competitive
equilibria or while raising
equilibria are Pareto optimal.
We've defined both
concepts earlier.
We'll raise the equilibrium
Pareto optimality.
So that's review.
I've mentioned that these
welfare theorems are true,
but we've never gone through
exactly under what conditions
and how the proofs go.
That's the first
welfare theorem.
The second welfare theorem,
any Pareto-optimal allocation
can be supported as a
competitive equilibrium
with transfers.
And again, we'll go
through the proofs.
Actually, two kinds of proofs
of the second welfare theorem.
One, I would say
is constructive.
It's matching up
first-order conditions.
And the second one is using
separating hyperplanes
in convex spaces.
The second is more general
than the first, in the sense
that it applies to
many environments.
But the first
constructive proof is
providing a lot of intuition.
So in some sense, when
these welfare theorems hold,
you can go back and forth
between optimal allocations
and competitive allocations.
A particular competitive
equilibrium is Pareto optimal,
but that doesn't mean that you
couldn't contemplate others.
It's associated with a
particular distribution
of wealth from
private ownership.
And if you want to get to
other redistribute wealth
and benefit, some at
the expense of others,
find another
Pareto-optimal allocation,
there's also a way to support
any additional one like that.
But it is going to require
these kinds of transfers.
So that's the overall
theme for today.
So let me remind you, paste
in some slides from earlier.
This is village India,
with income over time
and over households.
And you may remember this
gradient, that in some sense,
average income is going up
as you go from the landless
to the big landowners.
That's an income, but on the
same scale, so a bit harder
to see, it is nevertheless
present in consumption
as well, with this upsloping.
So in some sense, this
cross-sectional gradient
reflects the lambda
weights, so to speak,
when we solve for the
optimal allocation
of risk sharing in this
village India environment.
We maximize the lambda
weighted sum of utilities
and intuitively as
well as, in particular,
for particular functional forms,
the higher are the lambdas,
the higher would be
average consumption.
So that gradient reflects
the lambda, so to speak.
Now, we only looked
at Pareto optimality
when we did the optimal
allocation of risk sharing.
We didn't really link it up
to competitive equilibria,
but we're going
to do that today.
And in particular, we could ask
whether the implicit lambdas
in that gradient are
related to wealth.
Think about the village
achieving its allocation
of resources to competitive
markets and, in particular,
through private ownership.
Then, we should see a
correlation between the lambda
weights and other variables
that represent wealth.
So I don't think I showed
you this slide earlier.
It is in the paper risk and
insurance village India.
And here, you can
see a regression
of that gradient, the lambdas in
particular, that are backed out
from the empirical work, from
the optimal allocation of risk
sharing.
Those lambdas are
correlated with things
like landholding, where the
value of the bull that they own
and plow with and the
value of inheritance.
So that would seem
to suggest there
is some correlation between
wealth and the lambda weights,
although it's not uniform and
not true at all in Shirapur.
So it's mostly apparent in
only one of the three villages,
in Aurepalle.
And what you don't
know from this table
is that the ownership of
bulls and so on moves around
over time.
So it's not so representative
of wealth anyway.
So this might suggest that the
allocation in those villages,
even if achieved through
competitive market forces,
also includes some
kind of redistribution
from the upper-caste
landowners to the poor.
So let's turn to the
welfare theorems.
First one, suppose we had a
competitive allocation, denoted
x star, y star with
price p and wealth w.
And actually, this slide
treats it more generally.
A competitive equilibrium
with transfers.
A special case, of course,
of a competitive equilibrium
would be no transfers and
just private ownership.
But let's start with a
competitive equilibrium
with transfers.
And if preferences are rational
and locally nonsatiated,
that allocation x star, y star
is Pareto optimal or, for sure,
competitive equilibrium
or Pareto optimal.
Strikingly, you don't need much.
All you need is essentially
rational preferences
and local nonsatiation.
And intuitively, the
reason you need so little
is that we're given
a lot to begin with.
We're given the existence
of a competitive equilibrium
with transfers.
So we don't have to have all the
assumptions that go with that
that ensure that equilibrium.
That's kind of taken as
a given in the statement
of the problem.
In particular, we don't have
to talk about the consumption
sets of the agents,
other than they
have to be constructed
in a way that
is consistent with
local nonsatiation.
We don't have to say anything
about production sets,
other than evidently they're
nonempty because there's
a y star up here, although in
principle, that could be 0.
So very little is assumed.
So here's an illustration
in the Edgeworth box
of the first welfare theorem.
We start out with the
endowment, private ownership.
No production.
And we find prices such
that each of the two agents
here are maximizing.
And along their budget line,
it's the same line for each,
in some sense.
Household 1 giving up
Good 1, getting Good 2.
Household 2 going in
the opposite direction,
giving up Good 2
and getting Good 1.
And here's the equilibrium.
And you can see
how beautiful it is
because the marginal
rates of substitution
match up with the price ratio.
And we've achieved the
competitive equilibrium.
So competitive equilibrium
is Pareto optimal.
Of course, it's
not the only one.
There are many, many
others, as you can see.
But the first
welfare theorem just
starts with a particular
competitive equilibrium,
in this case, private ownership.
Now, how do we
prove the theorem?
The picture makes
it seem obvious.
But we want the proof
to be more general.
So if preferences are
locally nonsatiated, then,
in particular, if the Xi star
of the competitive equilibria
is maximizing under
Agent I's preferences,
maximizing in the sense that
it's the utility maximizing
object in h and i's budget set,
this is expenditures less than
or equal to wealth, then for
any other point Xi, which
is at least as good in
the preference as Xi star,
it must be the case
that the valuation
of that other allocation,
evaluated price's p,
is not less than,
is greater than
or equal to the
valuation of expenditures
at the competitive equilibrium.
That's kind a lot to take in.
The key part of it
is this implication,
and I used to have the
proof all written out.
But it takes like
six or seven lines.
Let me just give
you the intuition.
Suppose it weren't true?
Suppose that if pxi were
strictly less than pxi star.
Well, they're spending
everything they have.
So pxi star is their
wealth, and they could
spend less if they chose to.
If pxi were less
than pxi star, that
would be a point where
they're spending less.
However, finally, we come
back to the nonsatiation.
Draw a little ball
or circle around Xi.
If you remember the
statement, there
has to be a bundle
that's strictly preferred
to Xi that's close by.
Since it's close by, it is also
spending less than Xi star.
So now, there's
a preferred point
because Xi is at least
as good as Xi star.
This other point is going to
strictly dominate Xi and hence
dominate in the
preference at Xi star.
So there's a point in the
carrier of the budget set
which is strictly preferred
to the chosen point Xi
star, which contradicts
utility maximization.
Even took me quite
a while to say
it, but it's quite intuitive
when you think about it.
So this innocuous
little Lemma is
about to get used with the proof
of the first welfare theorem,
namely that a competitive
equilibrium is Pareto optimal.
Proof by contradiction.
No, it's not.
You say it is.
But I'm going to assume
it's not Pareto optimal.
Well, any point that's
not Pareto optimal means,
of course, you
guys all remember,
that there's a feasible
allocation, which
has the property
that it's at least as
good as the star competitive
allocation for all i
and strictly dominates for at
least one agent, in this case,
denoted i prime.
So that's what we mean by Xi
star not being Pareto optimal.
Now, clearly, for
the guys, Xi prime,
these bundles are strictly
preferred to the one chosen.
So they cannot be
in the budget set.
So we have a strict
inequality in expenditures
for those i prime guys.
But what about these guys that
were only weakly indifferent?
That could be a problem.
But no, we've got it covered.
By the previous
Lemma, we already
know that expenditures
are not less.
So we have strictly
greater, weakly greater
expenditures of the alternative
supposed dominating allocation
with the given
competitive allocation.
Let's sum up the values
over all the households
I, and we're going to
get a strict inequality.
So if it were true that there
exists an allocation, which
Pareto dominates the
competitive equilibrium,
it would be associated
at the equilibrium prices
with the higher
aggregate expenditure.
Then, the next step is to
review the definition of profit
maximization in a
competitive equilibrium,
meaning at yj star, the
valuation of profits
is not less than
any other feasible--
technologically
feasible vector yj.
And this is true for each firm
j, hence true for all of them.
So we can sum up over them.
And now we take this
statement for firms
with the statement on the
previous slide for households
and start using them
both simultaneously.
So from the previous slide,
we have the summation over I
pxi strictly dominates pxi star.
But we also had a competitive
equilibrium given to us
as an initial condition,
therefore feasible.
Therefore, xi star is equal
to omega bar plus y star.
And I should have pointed out.
I think I just skipped
over it too fast.
It's easiest to
think about prices
as being strictly positive.
So the only algebra going on
here is to take dot products,
take prices, put it
outside the parentheses,
then collect terms,
put it back inside.
So p dot xi, summation
over I, but Xi
is equal to a omega
bar plus yj star.
So if we put p outside and
then multiplied it inside,
we get price times the
odd quantity object
in each of the two terms.
Now, this last inequality
is the statement
of profit maximization.
Holding the valuation of the
aggregate endowment of fixed py
star j is no less than pyj.
And so now, we
again do this trick.
We take prices, put
in on the outside,
and look at all terms
inside the parentheses,
and we've got the Xi over here
and the omega bar and the yj
here.
So we collect those
terms together,
and we get this statement.
But if this is
greater than this,
then when you subtract
them, it's greater than 0.
So we finally arrive
at the contradiction.
Why?
Because this supposedly
Pareto-dominating point
has to be feasible in
the sense of the resource
constraint, which means this
has to be 0 for each component.
But by the argument achieved, it
can't be 0 for every component
or this could not
be greater than 0.
So it is not true
that it's feasible,
and that's the contradiction.
So it's a big proof
by contradiction.
So something's
happening along the way.
We're going to go to the
second welfare theorem now.
Any Pareto-optimal
allocation can be implemented
as a competitive equilibrium.
We can come back to this slide.
But here's the picture.
So we pick another
Pareto-optimal point
in that Edgeworth box.
Not this one that ran
through the endowment,
but something southwest of it.
So here's the endowment.
It's still there.
But now we're targeting
this other Pareto-optimal
allocation.
And the theorem
says there's a way
to redistribute wealth in
such a way to achieve it.
Note the marginal
rates of substitution
all match up for
Agent A and Agent B.
They're equal to sum price.
The price, p1 over p2,
is captured by the slope
of that, quote, "budget line."
But I really want
to say wealth line
because it is not a line that
runs through the privately
owned endowments.
So the previous slide,
which I skipped,
just says that those star
allocations for A and B
have the same slopes, which
are their marginal rates
of substitution.
And the marginal
rates of substitution
match up since they're
equal to each other.
Just something called gamma.
So that's the picture here.
Margin rates of
substitution are equal,
equal to the slope of
this wealth line, which
has a slope of gamma.
Now, the point is that
if they had started
from the endowment, this
thing, agent B would not
have enough wealth to get to
this Pareto-optimal allocation.
Conceptually, imagining
somehow the slopes
were the same if we had
drawn at those prices
gamma line, a budget line
going through the endowment,
Agent B has to be further out.
He has to have more wealth.
And where does that
wealth come from?
Well, Mr. A over here
gets to make the sacrifice
because he has gone southwest
of where he would be in terms
of the budget line through
the endowment if we insisted
that didn't go
through the endowment.
So all of that is
summarized on this slide.
If we start out with
that price ratio--
by the way, gamma 1, why?
Because the slope of
this thing is p1 over p2.
So we might as well set p2
equal to 1 as the numerator
because we're not
going to get any more
determination than that.
So it looks weird when
you write it like this,
but p equal p1 equal
gamma p2 equal to 1
are the prices we need.
Agents are going to
maximize at those prices,
depending on what
their wealth is.
But the allocation at
those prices for Agent B
costs more than the valuation
of Agent B's endowment
at the price gamma 1.
So what we propose
to do to Agent
B is to give them
the difference,
just give them
enough extra wealth
so that Agent B can afford
to buy the star bundle, which
requires more than the
valuation of his wealth
at his previous endowment.
So we call this a transfer
to B. And it's positive,
as you could see
from that diagram.
And A makes the sacrifice.
There seems to be a typo here.
It's probably--
anyway, you can see it.
The wealth transfer is the same.
It goes from B to A, and
this is written oddly
as if it were B's endowment
and B's expenditure.
But it's really referring
to the point on the box
here, which is simultaneously
the point for B and for A.
And so we just move southwest,
taxing A, and giving the tax
to B as a physical transfer.
So we found a price
equilibrium with transfers
that will support that target
Pareto-optimal allocation.
And it's possible to
do any one of them.
So if you go back here, this
was the private ownership Pareto
optimum.
There are all these other
Pareto-optimal allocations.
The theorem says, give me any
Pareto-optimal allocation,
and I can redistribute
wealth in such a way
as to support it as a
competitive equilibrium
with transfers.
Who gets taxed and who gets
the transfers depends on which
optimum we have
under consideration.
So this one takes more.
We're going to have to start
assuming stuff for the theorem
to be--
for sufficient conditions
for the theorem to be true.
We start with the
notation of our economy.
Consumption sets for the agents,
utility functions, endowments,
production sets, shares
in ownership of profits,
which is a quick review of the
notation you've seen before.
We're going to have to
assume that these consumption
sets essentially can be
formed by combinations
of quasi-concave functions.
This first line is
the most awkward.
And if you wish,
you could just think
about these being the
non-negative orthant,
that any positive
consumption bundle is fine.
I only put the most
general version
because I want to emphasize you
need restrictions on things.
Here's a statement about
the production sets.
Production sets Yj admit
a concave transformation
function called F.
What the heck does that mean?
Well, it means that for any
vector Y in the production set,
it can be represented
through some function
F, which is non-negative
when evaluated at that Y.
An example, because
this is really obscure,
suppose we have
an input z mapped
through production function
little f to get output q.
And we throw away
some of the output.
So we're not on the frontier,
we're in the interior.
Then if you rewrite this as f
of z minus q, it's non-negative.
So any input-output
combination, zq,
when evaluated under F,
which takes this form,
is non-negative.
So it really is quite innocuous.
But it's very
convenient just to talk
about this concave
transformation.
I should be emphasizing
again, these
are sufficient assumptions.
Something about consumption
sets being represented
by quasi-concave, this thing
being a concave transformation,
preferences to get
down to 3 are going
to be concave and
locally nonsatiated.
Locally nonsatiated
we had before.
Concave is new, which
you know from one
of the early lectures is
equivalent to preferences
being rational, convex,
continuous, and nonsatiated.
And finally, we have
an interior point
so that none of these
constraints or representations
are binding at 0, namely
non-negative, non-negative,
and even in terms
of the resource
constraint through
existing allocation, which
doesn't use up all of the
endowment plus production.
That's a technical
interior condition.
If we have all of these
things for this economy,
then we get the
second welfare theorem
stated in terms of the lambdas.
For any lambda, which is
a Pareto weight vector,
there exists a price vector p
in this L dimensional Euclidean
space.
And our vector of
wealth, one for each
of the i agents
such that x star,
y star, p and w star is
a Walrasian equilibrium
with transfers.
That's a formal
statement of the theorem.
Now, we're going to prove it.
And again, in the proof,
it's kind of easier
to assume that those lambdas
are strictly positive.
And it will generalize
to some of them being 0.
But it just gets in the way.
So let's make it a little
bit easier on ourselves.
The proof is constructive
and a bit tedious,
but it is
straightforward enough.
I'll try to guide you.
Step 1, characterize the
Pareto-optimal allocation.
That's the given that
we want to achieve
with a competitive
equilibrium of transfers.
2, characterize the conditions
for a competitive equilibrium
with transfer.
And then, 3, kind of
match up those conditions
and show that if we have the
conditions being satisfied
for the optimal
allocation, they're
going to be satisfied for
the competitive allocation,
if we choose properly.
This was the Pareto
problem, written out now
for the fully specified economy.
To find a Pareto-optimal
allocation,
we're going to find the
solution to maximizing
a lambda-weighted sum of
utilities, subject to resource
feasibility and
production constraints.
Max, subject to 15 and 16.
You've seen this many
times before, in like six
or seven applications already.
This is a full statement.
So the so-called Pareto problem.
Sometimes I call it
the math problem.
And you may remember that
solutions to this problem
generate Pareto-optimal
allocations
and that any Pareto-optimal
allocation can be achieved
as a solution to this problem.
So we're not losing anything
by restricting our attention
to these Pareto problems.
Second step is to
use the Lagrangian.
And the reason I was emphasizing
on the previous slide
all the concavity and
convexity is those,
it's not just getting
the necessary conditions
for an optimum from
the Lagrangian method,
those conditions are
also sufficient when
we have this kind of concavity.
I'll remind you momentarily.
So we've got production
constraints here.
We've got resource constraints.
So we're looking for an
allocation consumption
in the consumption
set, positivity
from those concave
transformations, and resource
clearing.
Here's the review slide.
We did this, the
first time it came up
was consumer optimization
subject to a budget.
And I said, oh, now we're going
to learn a cool tool, the tool
of constrained optimization.
So we maximize the function
subject to a series
of constraints.
We form the Lagrangian,
took derivatives,
and looked at the additional
first-order conditions,
which I'm about
to show you again
in the context of the problem.
So that was a review slide.
This is what we want to solve.
And the Lagrangian for
that is this problem.
So we want to solve to
maximize a lambda weighted sum
of utilities by choice of
an allocation Xi vector,
with now we start writing out
the L resource constraints.
But we put a Lagrange multiplier
gamma sub l in front of them,
as we were instructed to
do from the algorithm.
We also put on to the
Lagrangian these positivity--
these F's that represent the
production function frontier.
There are j of
those, and we come up
with some notation for
the Lagrange multiplier.
And then, when we differentiate
this whole system,
say with respect to the L-th
good for the I-th household,
we want to set the
Lagrangian derivative
to 0, which is the same thing as
lambda i U i prime add Xi star.
And where else does
that Xil enter?
It enters over here in
the resource constraint.
So it picks up a gamma.
And now, I start putting
stars on the solution
because the solution
will satisfy
these first-order conditions.
So there are special
allocations and
special Lagrange multipliers
because they are solutions.
Likewise, for the L-th
good, for the J-th firm,
set the derivative of
the Lagrangian with 0.
Where does that stuff happen?
It happens here.
So there's a picking
up a gamma l.
And over here, should
we pick up a derivative.
So this would be positive,
positive equal to 0.
So one of those terms
has to be negative.
We subtract it off, and
we get this expression.
The gamma l is the
derivative of the function
F with respect to yl.
This is for the J-th firm,
and we have this star
on the Lagrange multiplier.
So this equation 10 is
a set of conditions.
We need something, a
technical condition
that there can be something
that these things are all--
sorry.
Not technical, that the
constraints are all satisfied,
and the Lagrange multipliers
are not non-negative.
And then finally, this
complementary slackness
condition that the
Lagrange multipliers
times the respective
constraints equals 0.
Probably a lot to
review, but it is
in all this notation of the
environment exactly what you've
learned before.
The point is that equations
10 and these others
represent a solution to
the maximum Pareto problem.
And they're not just
necessary, they're
sufficient because
of all the concavity.
And in particular,
these utility functions
are strictly increasing.
And I said earlier, everybody
has a positive lambda.
It's enough that at least one
person has a positive lambda,
then we're going to have to have
the gammas being positive y.
That's this thing because here's
the marginal utility, which
is positive, a lambda,
which is positive.
So if the left-hand
side is positive,
the right-hand side is positive.
So that's where the positive
gammas are coming from.
So we know a little bit
more about the solution.
It's positive prices.
And from this complementary
slackness condition,
if the prices are all
positive, and this whole thing
has to be 0, then the interior
thing in brackets has to be 0.
So the resource
constraints are satisfied
at equality, as is natural.
So let's summarize.
We've characterized the
Pareto-optimal allocations,
x star, y star.
Also denoted x star,
y star at lambda
because we were given a
particular Pareto-optimal
allocation, hence
a particular lambda
weighted sum was used in
the objective function.
And it's the solution to 14,
which is that Pareto problem.
So it's Pareto optimal.
It's feasible, and
there are these gammas,
which are strictly
positive for every good l.
And these Lagrange
multiplies on the production
sets such that x star, y
star, gamma star, and phi star
satisfy 19 and 21.
19 and 21 were, yeah, something
happened in the process.
This is 10.
And 21 is the
feasibility constraint.
No.
It's right here.
21.
So much for characterizing
the Pareto-optimal allocation.
Let's look at the second part,
characterizing the equilibrium
with transfers, just separately.
Forget the first
part for a minute.
We have a given while raising
equilibrium with transfers,
meaning what?
Is x star, y star,
p and w star which
must be consistent with
consumer optimization, profit
maximization, resource
constraints being satisfied.
And since it's an equilibrium
with transfers, not necessarily
private ownership,
we have to make sure
that the distribution
of wealths are feasible,
that the wealths add
up to the valuation
of the endowment and profits.
So let's just take
this one at a time.
Consumer op, firms
op, and start look
at the first-order conditions.
Now, the third part of this is
putting these pieces together.
But at this point,
we're lost, right?
We don't remember
where we started.
We started from the
second welfare theorem.
So we were given a
Pareto-optimal allocation.
And we want to show that it
can be achieved as a price
equilibrium with transfers.
But we want to find the
components x star, y star, p
and w star of the
competitive equilibrium
with transfers that's
going to give us
back exactly the Pareto-optimal
allocations we started from.
So let's start with
the households.
We have a set of conditions for
the Pareto-optimal allocation,
and which are given because
we started with the Pareto
optimal-- now, you're not
used to seeing it like this.
We're usually writing lambda i
times the marginal utility is
equal to gamma.
Here it is.
All I did was divide
by lambda i and put it
on the right-hand side.
That was part of the necessary
and sufficient conditions
for the Pareto problem.
That's this.
So we're given this.
And we want to find Lagrange
multipliers mu and prices
p so as to satisfy this
optimizing first-order
condition per household i in
the competitive equilibrium
with transfers.
Now, what would you guess?
Well, we want-- this is
true, and we want this.
So let's guess that the
price that we want is
the gamma, Lagrange multiplier
on the resource constraint
for good l.
Pl equal gamma l.
And let's guess that the
mu that we want to find
is simply 1 over lambda i.
That's down here
summarized at the bottom.
And the final guess would be
that the wealth allocation
that we need in the
Pareto-optimal allocation
is just the valuation
of expenditures
at that Pareto-optimal
allocation.
I use my words carefully here.
The valuation, though, is at
the shadow prices gamma l.
If you go back to
the Pareto problem,
these gammas were arbitrary
Lagrange multipliers
on the resource constraint.
And we went to the math of all
the first-order conditions.
But really, what
it is, is how much
the solution that shadow price
reflects the incremental gain
in the objective function
to weakening the resource
constraint by a teeny amount.
So it is like a shadow price.
We often call the Lagrange
multiplier shadow prices.
It's really marginal
utility pricing
because we're incrementing
the weighted sum of utilities
a bit, hence like a derivative,
as we weaken the constraint.
So it's natural really that
these Lagrange multipliers l,
for good l, should
be shadow prices.
And the actual competitive
equilibrium prices
in the corresponding while
raising in equilibrium
with transfers.
This thing down here,
very simply written,
is that mu i is 1 over lambda i.
Oh, who cares?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't think of it that way.
Think of those beautiful
graphs of Kansas
and so on at the beginning.
OK?
So what this is
saying is mu i, which
is the marginal
utility of income,
the marginal utility of wealth
in the target competitive--
we're raising an
equilibrium with transfers
that we're trying to find.
The marginal utility of
wealth at that location
is inversely related to the
lambda weights in the Pareto
problem.
So the higher the
lambda weights,
the lower would be the
marginal utility of wealth.
Remember the first
two slides, I told you
that the gradient in
the consumption profile
had something to do
with the lambda weights.
And we could look
in the data to see
if it was related to wealth.
So this may look
upside down, but that's
only because mu i is the
marginal utility of wealth.
As wealth goes up,
marginal utility goes down.
So as lambda goes
up, and they're
more favored in
the Pareto problem,
the marginal utility of
wealth is going down.
And how does that happen?
It happens because
they get more wealth.
So there's kind of a 1 to 1
mapping, a monotone mapping,
between the lambdas
in the Pareto problem
and the wealth that corresponds
to the competitive equilibrium
with transfers.
And here it is falling
out in a very elegant way.
And this other thing at
the bottom, that Wi star,
is the valuation
of expenditures.
Again, that's pretty much
what we were doing in the box.
We took a target
allocation here,
that it wasn't a
competitive equilibrium
with private ownership.
But we could tax A
and transfer to B
so these stars here represented
the target Pareto-optimal
allocation.
And we're valuating
those expenditures
at the prices corresponding
to the budget line.
So you can start
them out with wealth
being at carefully
chosen prices,
the valuation of the star
Pareto-optimal allocation.
And that's this part
here at the bottom,
that the wealth
we give to Agent I
is just the valuation of the
Pareto-optimal allocation.
Now also is utility
maximizing allocation
at the prices gamma, gamma star.
We did all that for consumption.
Something else happens
automatically along the way,
namely when you look at
those first-order conditions,
we can define the marginal
rate of substitution
of good l for good k for agent
I. The lambdas cancel out,
right?
It's lambda I for a
household i for any good l.
So if we take the
derivative of utility
with respect to the two
goods, in this case l and k,
the lambda is in the numerator
and denominator it cancels out.
So this is the marginal rate
of substitution corresponding
to these optimizing first-order
conditions for household
I's, obviously equal to--
the I's, as I said,
are canceling out,
equal to the ratio of prices,
back to some other household h.
So this is the math of what
you already saw in the picture
that I've shown you three
times, the marginal rates
of substitution are
equated across households
and equal to the
common price ratio.
All of that coming from
the first-order conditions
that we've now formally derived.
One more step, firms.
So we have profit maximization.
Oh, are you lost again?
I say that a bit tongue in
cheek because everything
is equivalent to
everything else.
And it's easy to
get turned around
and forget our starting point.
So we started with a
Pareto-optimal allocation.
We looked at the first-order
conditions, which
are necessary and sufficient.
And we got this thing.
So this is true.
Now, we want to find the
conditions for profit
maximization in a competitive
equilibrium with transfers.
So we want this equation
to be satisfied.
As long as we can choose
the gammas and the piece
appropriately, we'll be done,
and it's easy to choose them.
P, we already
pinned down already.
p sub l.
The price of good l
is the shadow price
derived previously gamma l.
And it just remains to figure
out what this delta l is.
Can we find that Lagrange
multiplier somehow?
Searching?
Sure.
Let's let it equal to
the associated Lagrange
multiplier and the solution
to the Pareto problem.
And again, because all these--
if you can satisfy this because
it's necessary and sufficient,
then we have profit max.
So we just pick the delta
and the p to be what--
obviously, it would
be true so that we
have profit maximization.
So we're almost there.
We have a solution.
We started with a target
Pareto-optimal allocation.
We have a solution to
the household problem
in the competitive
equilibrium with transfers.
We have a solution
to the first problem.
So what do we know
about feasibility,
and what do we know about
the allocation of wealth?
So we know what householdized
wealth has to be,
as I've been saying.
It's just the valuation of
the assignment, the Xi star
assignment in the Pareto problem
at the prices gamma equal to p.
So that's the wealth
of household I.
Let's sum them up and
make sure it's feasible.
So we sum up the valuation
of the target at prices p.
But now we do this trick.
Bring p outside.
It's common.
I suppose it's strictly positive
in all the components too,
just to make it easy.
Then, this summation
of-- because of we
started with a
Pareto optimum, so it
had to be resource feasible.
So now, we use that fact, that
the summation over i Xi star
must be equal to
the summation over i
of the endowment plus output.
So demand is equal to supply.
Demand is equal to
endowments plus production.
And then, you can
rewrite the p dot yj's
to be consistent with the
claim on those profits
under these ownership
shares, theta ij.
It probably would have
been clearer if p were also
still multiplying each part.
But it's there.
It's just outside
the parentheses.
And then, we group--
finally, we do put
the p's on the inside.
And we have what we
want because this
is total wealth in the economy.
It's the total value.
It's the valuation of
the aggregate endowment
plus profits.
And it adds up to the
sum of the wealths
that we need, according to
the solutions to the consumer
maximization problem.
So now we're done.
This last slide is
always a bit mysterious.
It's like, well, why do we
have to do anything else?
Well, again, just
remember the definition
of a competitive
equilibrium with transfers.
Because it's transfers,
it's specified
not in terms of
private ownership
but in terms of wealth.
So whatever those
wealths are, they
have to add up to the total.
That's what this
slide is all about.
So that's what we call
the constructive proof,
is just using finite
dimensional Euclidean spaces,
putting in a lot of concavity,
convexity, et cetera,
then sort of matching up
first-order conditions.
But the theorem
holds more generally.
The second welfare
theorem is true,
even without making special
assumptions about the commodity
space and so on.
A step along the
way is something
called the quasi-equilibrium
with transfers, quasi
meaning it's not quite
fully consumer maximization.
But it's going to be close.
So here's the definition.
An allocation, x star, y
star and a price vector p,
constitute a price
quasi-equilibrium
with transfers if we can
find wealth levels that
add up to the total
wealth if each firm
J is profit maximizing.
So far so good.
Nothing different.
Here's the difference.
Household i, this
condition has to be true.
If Xi star is the
allocation we want
in the definition of the
equilibrium with transfer price
quasi-equilibrium
with transfers,
if you start with
that Xi star and there
were an allocation
that's strictly
better for household i, then
it costs at least as much
as the wealth assignment in
the price quasi-equilibrium
with transfers.
It's kind of a mouthful.
One way to put this,
though, is that Wi star
is the valuation of
expenditures at the equilibrium,
at the equilibrium Xi star.
So then this says pxi, the
valuation of this arbitrary
Xi, which is strictly
preferred, the valuation
is not less than the
valuation of pxi star.
That means that pxi
star costs no more
or is cost minimizing
over the upper contour
set of allocations
that are associated
with strictly more utility.
So you've seen this
before, way back when.
When we did the consumer
utility maximization problem,
I pointed out that this
is kind of a dual thing.
Instead of maximizing
utility subject to budgets,
we minimized the budget
necessary to achieve
a given level of utility.
In fact, we did a lot with that.
We did Hicksian substitutions
versus Walrasian substitutions
and so on.
We had a whole lecture on it.
So here it is again,
except so instead
of assuming utility
maximization,
we're going to assume
cost minimization.
That's the only difference
between a regular equilibrium
with transfers and
this quasi-equilibrium
with transfers.
The feasibility of the
allocation is the same.
So I'll show you
the theorems now.
But just to say, when we do
the second welfare theorem,
we're going to say that it's
a price quasi-equilibrium
with transfers.
And then, given the
structure of the economy,
you may need a little
bit more to establish
that cost minimization
corresponds
with utility maximization.
So suppose that the production
sets are strict or convex,
the preference relations
are rational convex
and satisfy local
nonsatiation, then
any Pareto-optimal allocation
has a price p such that x star,
y star p is a price
quasi-equilibrium
with transfers.
So it's looking pretty
similar, but we're
going to prove this
in a different way.
And it's going to be
a proof that works
for quite arbitrary spaces.
And the proof
that's going to work
has to do with
separating hyperplanes.
So let me remind you
what that was about.
Actually, this is not
quite the right slide.
This was a review slide about
a supporting hyperplane.
The better slide was,
we had two convex sets
that were tangent at a point.
And then we were able to
draw this hyperplane that
would be tangent to the common
slope of the two convex sets.
So all you needed
for the existence
of supporting and
separating hyperplanes
is a presumption that
the sets are convex.
Here's a picture of it.
We've seen versions
of this before.
Here's one production set.
Here's another production set.
Here's the endowment somewhere
here, I think it was.
And so we add up the production
sets and the endowments,
and we get this sort
of outer frontier.
The point being, it's
defining a convex set.
Things on the frontier
but also interior.
Any linear combinations
of things in the interior
is also in the interior.
What's this other monster here?
This thing looks like
an indifference curve.
But, in fact, we have
many, many households.
So what the heck is it?
Well, it's this thing.
It's the upper contour set.
It's the set of allocations,
which are weakly preferred
to the allocation x
star and summed up
over all the households.
So that's this thing that looks
like an indifference curve.
But because we have convexity,
this upper contour set
is also convex.
So now, we have two convex sets.
We have a supporting
hyperplane for both of them,
separating supporting
hyperplane.
And we're going to
define the price system.
So this is kind
of a graphical way
to think about that
constructive proof
without taking
first-order conditions
and matching up
Lagrange multipliers.
We're defining using the
convexity and the separating
supporting hyperplane
theorems to get the prices.
So in 1954, Debreu
worked all this out.
He called his equilibrium
a valuation equilibrium,
as distinct from a
competitive equilibrium.
Pareto optimality was
defined the same way.
The environment is similar.
We have a finite number of
households getting allocations
in their consumption sets.
But when it says the consumption
set is a subset of this L,
it does no longer mean a finite
dimensional Euclidean space.
It's an arbitrary linear
space, conveniently
denoted L for linear.
Preferences have a
complete ordering.
That's rationality.
Producers J have
a production set,
choosing objects in the set.
Also a subset of
the linear space.
Market clearing
looks pretty similar.
x equal y plus 6e or
x minus y equals 6e,
where x is the summation
over households,
y is the summation
over producers,
and xi is the endowment.
So we actually call a state
of the economy something
that's attainable being in the
production sets, consumption
sets, and satisfying
the resource constraint.
So then, we get to the theorems.
First and second
welfare theorems
are similar, although the
assumptions are a little bit
different.
Evaluation equilibrium, i.e.
competitive equilibrium,
is Pareto optimal.
What does the price
system look like?
In these general
linear spaces, it's
just called a linear
functional, meaning
that it's retaining additivity.
If you take the valuation
of a weighted average of two
bundles, it's the
weighted average
of the valuation
of the two bundles.
Seems quite natural.
Obviously, for finite
dimensional Euclidean spaces
and the dot product,
this holds automatically.
This is a generalization
of that idea.
So a valuation equilibrium is
attainable, maximizes utility,
subject to the budget,
and maximizes profits,
where the price system is this
valuation function v. This
is literally utility
maximization because it
says that if it's in the budget,
it is not preferred to Xi.
If that weren't true, if you
had a point in the budget that
were strictly preferred
to the allocation Xi0,
then it would be chosen.
So that would contradict
utility maximization.
The second welfare theorem
of valuation equilibrium
is a Pareto optimum
welfare theorem.
What we need, we need convexity
of the consumption sets
and a little bit more about
convexity of preferences.
We did not need this previously.
When we had finite
dimensional Euclidean spaces,
I made a big deal of
saying all we needed
was local nonsatiation.
We need no satiation here.
We also need a little bit more
about convexity of consumption
sets and preferences.
So you're trying for
something bigger, something
that works for a very,
very large number
of economic
environments, you need
to assume a little bit more.
The second welfare
theorem, any Pareto optimum
can be achieved as a
valuation equilibrium.
So again, more things
about consumption sets.
When your combinations of points
in the set are also in the set,
sets closed.
Production sets,
when aggregated up,
the aggregated
production set is convex.
And here, either L is finite
dimensional or if infinite
or other dimensional, Y
has an interior point.
I know this is really,
really abstract.
I'm going to show you a couple
of applications momentarily.
And the theorem is,
assuming the 3, 4,
and 5, every Pareto-optimal
allocation, which is not
a satiation point, is associated
with a nontrivial continuous
linear function, where we have
a condition for households
and a condition for firms.
So here, the condition for
households is that if Xi,
we have the Pareto optimal
allocation Pareto Xi0.
We have an allocation that
is strictly weakly preferred
to Xi0 and is in
the consumption set,
then this implies the valuation
of that other allocation Xi
is not less than the
valuation of Xi0.
This corresponds to
cost minimization.
And again, just reverse it.
If the valuation were
less than Xi0, then
that other point is, say,
better, maybe indifferent.
But because we have
local nonsatiation, just
like the Lemma, we could
construct something close
by which is strictly better
and in the budget set for Xi0.
So that would be
a contradiction.
So this is the cost
minimization part.
This is why it's going to
be a quasi-equilibrium, not
a full equilibrium.
So I feel like it
took a lot of work
to get through all of this.
The main takeaways
are, there's a way
to do things more generally
with separating and supporting
hyperplanes, as long as we
have sufficient convexity.
I took the time to take you
through Debreu's article.
It's really very similar,
apart from changes in notation,
to what we did with the finite
dimensional Euclidean spaces.
But it applies to
other economies,
in particular,
competitive equilibria
in the space of
contracts, including
the possibility of
randomized allocations
that we've used before.
So I think I mentioned
contracts with options,
like CDs where you
could withdraw early
or pensions where you could
decide to take a lump sum
or take an annuity.
I gave you those as examples
of contracts with options.
And then we had a
couple of lectures
talking about contracts.
I'm sparing you
working out through all
of that notation how the
contracts with lotteries
and indeed without
grids, so measures,
can be mapped into Debreu's
valuation equilibrium,
and hence we get the
welfare theorems.
OK.
So that's all for today.